بدا الجيش الاسرائيلي بناء جدار عند
مستوطنه المطلي الشماليه المواجهه لقريه
كفركلا اللبنانيه الجدار يبلغ طوله نحو
كيلومتر واحد اما ارتفاعه فعده
امتار
نتوقف مع هذا الخبر لنناقش من زاويتين اي
فائده امنيه يمكن ان تجنيها اسرائيل من
بناء هذا الجدار وماذا تحمل اسرائيل ايضا
في جعبتها نحو الحدود
الشماليه السلام عليكم قال وزير الخارجيه
اللبناني عدنان منصور ان الجدار العازل
الذي باشرت اسرائيل ببنائه على الحدود يقع
خارج الاراضي اللبنانيه واكد انه سيكون
هناك رد قوي على اي تعد على الجانب
اللبناني وكان الجيش الاسرائيلي قد اعلن
عن هذا المشروع في يناير الماضي واكد انه
جرى التنسيق مع قوات اليونيفل والجيش
اللبناني جدار حدودي جديد شرعت اسرائيل في
تشييده هذه المره على حدودها مع لبنان
فعلى طول كيلومتر واحد تقريبا سيعلو جدار
اسما بارتفاع يتراوح بين خمسه وسبعه امتار
يفصل بين بلده كفركلا اللبنانيه ومستوطن
لمطل الاسرائيليه حسب المتحدث باسم الجيش
الاسرائيلي العقيد امت فشر تولت قوات
الامم المتحده في لبنان يونيفيل التنسيق
بين الجانبين اللبناني والاسرائيلي اما
الجيش اللبناني فسير دورياته وراقبت عناصر
من مديريه الشؤون الجغرافيه تطورات تحسبا
من حصول خرق اسرائيلي لما يعرف بالخط
الازرق تمتد الحدود المؤقته بين لبنان
واسرائيل على طول
121 كت حيث تنتشر الاسيجه الشائكه بيد ان
هذه المنطقه خصصتها اسرائيل بجدار اسمنتي
داخل حدودها فهنا تعرف المنطقه باسم بوابه
فاطمه التي انسحب منها اخر الجنود
الاسرائيليين عام 2000 مما اعطاها رمزيه
خاصه لدى مناصري المقاومه وحزب الله
وبالرغم من انتشار الدشم الاسرائيليه
ونقطه عسكريه لبنانيه فان هذه المنطقه لم
تشهد تطورا عسكريا يذكر خلال حرب لبنان
الثانيه عام 2006 بل تميز هذا الكيلومتر
من الاسفلت باستقطاب مسيرات لحزب الله
والفصائل الفلسطينيه واخرين غالبا ما
يلقون بالحجاره باتجاه الجنود
الاسرائيليين وسيحب الجدار العتيد الرؤيه
بين الجانبين وسيوفر الحمايه للجنود وعمال
البساتين من عمليات اطلاق نار محتمله
يتخوف منها المتحدث باسم الجيش الاسرائيلي
في اشاره منه الى الاشتباكات التي وقعت
على الحدود عند بلده لدي اللبنانيه عام
2010 واسفرت عن مقتل ثلاثه جنود لبنانيين
وضابط اسرائيلي برتبه مقدم وجرح جنديين
اسرائيليين اخرين وبذلك يضاف هذا الجدار
الى قائمه من الجدران والاسلاك الشائكه
القائمه على حدود اسرائيل البريه مع
الاراضي الفلسطينيه ومصر حيث اقامت على
الحدود مع الضفه الغربيه عام 2002 ما يعرف
بالجدار العازل خشيه تسلل مقاتلي المقاومه
الفلسطينيه وللهدف ذاته جرى تعزيز الحدود
مع قطاع غزه بعد الانسحاب عام 2005 اما
على الحدود مع مصر فاقام اسرائيل الاسلاك
الشائكه ونقاط المراقبه لمواجهه تسلل
المهاجرين الافارقه وعمليات تهريب
السلاح معنا في هذه الحلقه من تلبيب ايال
عليمه المراسل العسكري للاذاعه
الاسرائيليه ومن الناصره الكاتب الصحفي
انطوان شلحت اهلا بضيفي سيد ال عليمه
لماذا هذا
الجدار
في الواقع هذا الجدار ياتي
لتعزيز الامن خاصه بالنسبه للمواطنين
الاسرائيليين الذين يسكنون في بلده المطله
وبشكل خاص للمزارعين الذين يخرجون الى
الحقول المحاذيه للقريه اللبنانيه كفر كلا
والذين يتعرضون بين الحين والاخر لرشق
الحجاره او ما شبه ذلك ولكن بغض النظر عن
هذه
الاحتكاكات ربما
القول الدائمه او اليوميه التي تحدث في
هذه المنطقه فلا شك ان القلق الاكبر يكمن
مما شهدته هذه الحدود اثناء ذكرى يوم
النكبه في شهر ماي الماضي حيث كانت هناك
بعض المسيرات
والقلق الاكبر يكمن في احتمال توجه مثل
هذه المسيرات خاصه خصه في هذه المنطقه
القريبه والذي لا حيث لا يوجد هناك اي
مسافه بين البلده الاسرائيليه والقريه
اللبنانيه وبناء على هذه الاعتبارات تقرر
بناء هذا الجدار على مقطع لا يزيد عن
كيلومتر واحد ولكن يستطيع الفصل بين
البلده الاسرائيليه والقريه اللبنانيه
ولكن كيلومتر واحد يفي بالغرض الذي تشير
اليه
الان
ايه الاعتقاد هو ان هذا الكيلومتر او هذه
المسافه الصغيره تكفي لتوفير الامن
للمزارعين لسكان هذه البلده وخاصه على
خلفيه المظاهرات
التي تقام في هذه المنطقه بشكل اعتيادي
وتعرض المزارعين او الشعور عدم ال الامان
او عدم الارتياح في صفوف سكان هذه البلده
اذاء المسافه القريبه بين الطرفين
الاسرائيلي
واللبناني في هذه الحاله سيد انطوان شلحت
هل السبب الحقيقي هو ما كان يشير اليه سيد
عليمه قبل قليل وهو الخوف من تحركات
جماهيريه اكثر مما ربما يتعرض له
المزارعون بين فتره
واخرى يعني هذه هي الحجه الاسرائيليه
الرسميه في الظاهر ولكنني اعتقد ان اقامه
هذا
الجدار تاتي في سياق حمله متواتره لاقامه
الكثير من الجدران في السنوات الاخيره كما
ذكر تقرير مراسلكم اخي محمد و انت تعلم ان
مقاربه الحكومه
الحاليه لكل الاوضاع في المنطقه التي
تعززت في اثر ثورات ربيع الشعوب العربيه
هي المقاربه الامنيه يعني هي تنظر الى كل
التطورات سواء في العلاقات الثنائيه او في
العلاقات مع المنطقه من خلال المنظور
الامني ولذلك اقيم هذا الجدار وفي قرار
الحكومه جاء ان في المرحله الاولى سيمتد
هذا الجدار على طول كيلومتر واحد ولكن من
المحتمل ان يمتد في المستقبل على طول
كيلومترات اخرى وايضا هناك عمليات اقامه
الجدار على طول منطقه الحدود مع مصر التي
تبلغ 230 كترا واقيم
الجدار الفاصل الذي
يفصل منطقه داخل منطقه الخط الاخضر والضفه
الغربيه وهناك ايضا قرار ضمني باقامه جدار
في المستقبل بعد الانتهاء من اقامه الجدار
مع مصر في منطقه الحدود مع الاردن اذا
اردت ان اوجز كل هذه العمليه عمليه اقامه
الجدران بالاضافه الى ارتباطها
بالمقاربة وعلى الكينونه الاسرائيليه
بالاضافه الى علامات اخرى قد نشير اليها
اذا اتسع المجال في سياق لاحق نعم في هذه
الحاله سيد ال عليمه هل فعلا هناك هذا
الخطر مما يجعل دوله اسرائيل في النهايه
قلعه تحيط بها الجدران من من من كل
مكان في الواقع لا لا لا نستطيع ان نرفض
ما ذكره الضيف في ايه الناصره حول ربما
المعاني ايه الداخليه الكامنه وراء عمليه
اقامه هذا هذا السور الواقف في منطقه
الحدود الشماليه واضح انه في نهايه الامر
ربما هذه قد تكون النتيجه الاخيره بان
تكون اسرائيل محاصره وراء الجدران في كافه
الجبهات والمناطق رغم انه في كل منطقه
هناك اعتبارات تختلف تماما فلا نستطيع
المقارنه بين هذه الصوره في منطقه الحدود
الشماليه او عمليه بناء السياج في الحدود
المصريه هناك اعتبارات اخرى اسباب اخرى
ولكن بلا شك في نهايه الامر النتيجه
الاخيره سوف تتمثل ب محاصره اسرائيل وراء
هذه الجدران وهذه الاسوار بلا شك يعني في
في في بيئه مثل الشرق الاوسط و هناك اسلحه
دمار شامل و وطيران وصواريخ وهناك حتى
التهديد الايراني الذي تتحدث عنه اسرائيل
ما القيمه الحقيقيه لجدران اسمنتي سواء
كانوا طوله خمسه او او عشره
يعني لا اعتقد انه في نهايه الامر اسرائيل
تعتمد فقط على هذه الوسائل الدفاعيه
الوسائل الدفاعيه هي جزء اخر من النظريه
الامنيه
الشامله بالنسبه لاسرائيل بلا شك انه الى
جانب هذه الجوانب هناك قدرات هجوميه تعكف
اسرائيل على تطويرها على بنائها فمن هذه
الناحيه لا اعتقد
ان المضمون هو دفاعي فقط بل هناك قدرات
اخرى وبلا شك هذا قد اتضح خلال السنوات
الاخيره هل هناك امكانيه ان يمتد هذا
الجدار من كيلومتر الى ان يصبح اطول من
ذلك في الفتره
المقبله لا لا
اعتقد بغض النظر عن الجوانب اللوجستيه
والفنيه المتعلقه بمثل هذه العمليه وبلا
شك التكلفه التي قد تؤدي اليها في نهايه
الامر المشكله كانت مشكله ضيقه او او
مشكله محدوده لتوفير الامن لسكان هذه
البلده لا اعتقد ان اسرائيل تتجه الى
توسيع هذا السور او الى بناء سور يمتد على
حوالي 100 ك او اكثر من ذلك وهي مسافه
الحدود بين اسرائيل ولبنان لا اعتقد انه
في نهايه الامر الهدف هو بناء الصوره
الصيني الجديد وان تكون اسرائيل وراء هذا
الصوره شكرا جزيلا لك يا العليم المراسل
العسكري للاذاعه الاسرائيليه شكرا لحضورك
هذا الجزء من البرنامج اما الكاتب والصحفي
انطوان سلحت فسيظل معنا لاتمام هذه الحلقه
نعود اليكم في الجزء الثاني لنناقش ما اذا
كانت اسرائيل لديها ربما المزيد في هذه
السياسه تجاه حدودها الشماليه مع لبنان
بشكل خاص لنا عوده بعد
[موسيقى]
قليل اهلا بكم من جديد في هذه الحلقه التي
نتناول فيها هذا الجدار الذي بنته اسرائيل
بطول كيلومتر عند بلده المطله الشماليه
المواجهه لقريه كفركلا اللبنانيه نرحب مره
اخرى بضيفنا الكاتب الصحفي انطوان شلحت
وانضم الينا الان من بيروت الخبير في
الشؤون العسكريه العميد المتقاعد نزار عبد
القادر اذا اهلا بضيفنا من من لبنان سيد
عبد القادر بتقديرك ما الخطوره التي يمكن
ان يشكلها هذا الجدار على لبنان حتى وان
بني من الناحيه القانونيه البحته داخل
الاراضي
الاسرائيليه انا اعتقد بانه لا يمكن
للبنان الاعتراض على مثل هذا الامر
وبالفعل السلطه اللبنانيه وفقا لمعلوماتي
الدقيقه يعني لم تعترض عندما طرح هذا
الموضوع في الاجتماعات الثلاثيه التي تجري
في الناقوره وعلى اساس ان اسرائيل اكدت
بان هذا نا لن يكون على الخط الازرق
نهائيا والذي لا يعترف لبنان بانه هو
الحدود النهائيه بل هو خط امني مؤقت انما
سيكون وراء الخط الازرق اي داخل الاراضي
الاسرائيليه وفقا ل المنظور اللبناني لذلك
يعني لم يعترض لبنان على هذا الموضوع ولكن
يعني دون شك لبنان ياخذ احتياطات يراقب اي
بناء الجدار يراقب بناء الجدار وفقا لما
تحدثت عنه اسرائيل في اجتماعات اللجنه
الثلاثيه والجدار في رايي لن يكون سب
وثمانيه
امتار الجدار طبعا سيتبع تضاريس الارض
والارض في بعض المناطق هناك من جهه
اسرائيل هي منخفضه اكثر من الجهه
اللبنانيه لذلك من الجهه اللبنانيه يعني
لن يتعدى ارتفاع الحائط الا يمكن ان يكون
في منطقه بوابه فاطمه اكثر من مترين او
متر و90 سن لذلك يعني لا يمكن لبنان من
الناحيه القانونيه ليس هناك اي تهديد
للسلامه اللبنانيه او لل للامن اللبناني
ليس هناك اعتداء عقاريا على لبنان ولا
يشكل هذا الحائط اي مكسب استراتيجي او
عسكري يمكن ان تجنيه اسرائيل بالواقع هو
لبنان نشر هلا الجيش في اثناء عمليه بناء
ال الحائط لمراقبه هذا الموضوع ومراقبه كل
التحركات الاسرائيليه ال اثناء عمليات
البناء وفي نفس الوقت تنتشر قوات يونيفيل
على طول هذا الخط من اجل منع اي احتكاك مع
اي جهه كان بين ال الجانب الاسرائيلي
والجانب اللبناني لذلك بالواقع هذا الحائط
لا يشكل اي عائق استراتيجي بالنسبه لنظام
المدافعه لبنانيه عن الارض اللبنانيه كما
انه من وجهه النظر العسكريه البحته او من
وجهه النظر اللبنانيه فهو لا يشكل اي
انتهاك للسياده اللبنانيه ولا يعطي
اسرائيل اي يعني حسنه استراتيجيه يمكن ان
تستعملها في المستقبل في اي اشتباك قد
يحصل بينها وبين لبنان قد قد يكون الامر
فعلا كذلك سيد عبد القادر ولكن الا يكون
هذا الجدار قد حرم بعض اللبنانيين او
بالاحرى بعض الزوار الذين ياتون وكانوا في
حركه رمزيه يلقون بالحجاره على الجانب
الاسرائيلي وغيره هذا من الناحيه الاحتفاء
كما كانت تتم انتهى الان او سينتهي
بالاحرى ن نعم انا انا بقول لك يعني هلا
الحقيقه هذا الفولكلور كان يجب ان ينتهي
منذ زمن طويل انا افهم يعني شعور
اللبنانيين وللقيام بمثل هذا العمل بعد
الانسحاب الاسرائيلي من لبنان او حتى بعد
وقف اطلاق النار بعد الحرب في عام 2006
لكن
يعني تجاوزنا بالواقع هذا النوع من
الفولكلور انا بدي احكي كلمه مهمه هون
يعني مثلا حادث اللي جرى في عديسي وذهب
ضحيته جنديان لبنانيان ومدني لبناني ومن
الجهه الاخرى مقدم اسرائيلي هذا الموضوع
بالواقع شك شكل تطورا خطيرا يعني وهو وقع
ضمن سياسه خطا معين من الجانبين وقد وضع
بالفعل امكانيه ان ان يتوسع هذا الاشتباك
وان يكون هناك يعني مواجه واسعه ما بين
الاسرائيليين واللبنانيين لولا من نجاح
يعني الجهود الدبلوماسيه
والنظام كما نقول اداره الازمات الممثل
باللجنه الثلاثيه التي تجتمع في الناقوره
لذلك يعني يجب ان لا يبقى امن الحدود
اللبنانيه وامن القرى اللبنانيه المتاخمه
وموضوع النتائج الدراماتيكي التي يمكن ان
تترتب على اي خطا
يرتكب رهينه ل لرغبه ناس للقيام بنوع من
الفولكلور على على
الحدود نعم نعم ولكن ان تكتفي اسرائيل
وهنا اسال سيد انطوان شلحت ان تكتفي
اسرائيل ب بهذه الثغره ان صح التعبير وكيل
متر واحد هل يدل انها لا ليست لديها هواجس
كبرى
في في حدودها مع مع لبنان تستدعي خطوات
اكثر راديكاليه من
ذلك يعني من الصعب التكهن بهذا لان القرار
بحد ذاته الان يتحدث عن كيلومتر واحد ولكن
له شق ثان هو احتمال ان يجري تمديد هذا
الجدار في مرحله لاحقه حتى الان يعني
الهواجس الامنيه بين مزدوجين التي تعتبر
اسرائيل انها تتحدى امنها القومي تتمثل في
اربعه هواجس الهاجس الاول طبعا ما يسميه
نتنياهو البرنامج النووي الايراني الهاجس
الثاني الصواريخ وقذائف الهان والهاجس
الرابع ما يعتبر انه حدود مخترقه والهاجس
الهاجس الثالث اسف والهاجس الرابع هو ما
يسمى بالحرب
البرانيه ولكن ما يهم في مساله هذا الجدار
ارتباطا بسائر اعمال بناء الجدران الاخرى
والاعمال اللاحقه ببناء جدار على منطقه
الحدود مع الاردن هو المدلول السياسي لهذه
العمليه المدلول السياسي يقول ان اسرائيل
تنظر الى الشرق الاوسط فقط من المنظار
الامني العسكري
وانها لا تنوي ان تفعل شيئا على المستوى
السياسي في سياق التوصل الى تسويه مع
الدول التي لديها نزاعات سواء نزاعات
تاريخيه وجوديه او نزاعات حدوديه وهذه هي
الخطوره في المساله وانا كما قلت في بدايه
حديثي ادرج هذا الجدار في اطار عقليه
الجدار التي تسيطر على المؤسسه السياسيه
الاسرائيليه ودعنا لا ننسى اخ محمد ان
رئيس الحكومه الحاليه بنيامين نتنياهو هو
من حزب
الحروته اسس حزب
الحروته الذي سقى ما يسمى بنظريه الجدار
الحديدي ولذلك نحن نرى عوده الان الى
نظريه الجدار الحديدي في التعامل مع
المحيط الاقليمي ومع الشعوب العربيه
وبالاساس مع الشعب العربي الفلسطيني
والشعب اللبناني بمعنى ان الذي يريد ان
يتعامل مع اسرائيل يجب ان يتعامل معها فقط
من مفهوم الجدار الحديدي الامر الذي يصد
الافق امام اي امكانيه
اخرى لبناء مستقبل مغاير في هذه المنطقه
وكل ذلك بسبب هذه السياسه الاسرائيليه
المتغطيه نعم سيد شلحت ان تقدم اسرائيل
على هذا الجدار حتى وان كان كيلومتر لكن
داخل اراضيها من الناحيه القانونيه في حين
لم تفعل ذلك مثلا مع الضفه الغربيه هي لم
تفعلها على حدود 67 فعلتها واقامت هذا
الجدار داخل الضفه الغربيه وداخل الاراضي
الفلسطينيه هل له مدلول
معين بالتاكيد يعني هذا يرتبط بالاطباء
الاقليميه او الاطماع الجغرافيه الصهيونيه
في المنطقه الشماليه الاطماع مختلفه عن
اطماعها في منطقه الضفه الغربيه انت تعلم
ان الضفه الغربيه لا تسمى ضفه غربيه
باللغه بالقاموس الاسرائيلي انما تسمى
منطقه يهودا والسامره حسب التسميه
التوراتيه ورئيس الحكومه وغيره من
المسؤولين الاسرائيليين يكررون في الاونه
الاخيره ان وجود اسرائيل في منطقه الضفه
الغربيه هو ليس وجودا اجنبيا لان الضفه
الغربيه هي جزء من ارض اسرائيل التاريخيه
المذكوره في التوراه ولذلك جاء الجدار
الفاصل في منطقه 67 واكل اجزاء كبيره من
الارض الفلسطينيه التي تعكس الاطماع
الاسرائيليه في تلك المنطقه نعم
سيد نزار عبد القادر وزير الخارجيه
اللبناني عدنان منصور قال بان سيكون هناك
رد قوي على اي تعد على الجانب اللبناني في
اشاره تحذيريه مبكره ان صح التعبير هل كان
لمثل هذا التصريح لزوم في ضو المعطيات
التي قللت من خطوره وشان هذا
الجدار انا كما سبق وقلت في السؤال الاول
اللي طرحته علي بانه الجيش اللبناني في
حاله انذار وم شر على طول هذه المنطقه
الحدوديه بكثافه الان ويراقب الوضع عن كثب
يعني تقول اسرائيل بانها ستبني هذا الحائط
ضمن فلسطين المحتله ولكن نحن نراقب هذا
الوضع و تصريح الوزير في رايي يعكس هذا
الموضوع يعني هلا تعليقا على الحديث اللي
جرى بينك وبين الاخ الصحافي من من فلسطين
انطوان
شلحت يعني الاستاذ انطوان شلحت انا اعتبر
انه اسرائيل مسكونه مسكونه بالهاجس الامني
وكل شيء تفكر فيه اسرائيل ينطلق من ارضيه
امنيه وهذا هو الخطا الكبير في الفكر
الامني الاسرائيلي الامن هو قرار سياسي
بامتياز وهذا القرار السياسي يجب ان يكون
ذو افق واسع اي لا امن بدون سلام مع
الفلسطينيين اولا ومع الدول المج ثانيا
لذلك بناء جدار القسطنطينيه لن يحمي
اسرائيل في حال تواجدت نوايا وتواجد
امكانيات عند اي طرف عربي محيط باسرائيل
او لدى المجتمع الفلسطيني الموجود ضمن
سواء الضفه المحتله او في غزه او في
فلسطين 48 لذلك بالواقع الوضع الاسرائيلي
صعب جدا هلا الاسرائيليين بيدرك بانهم مع
لبنان بالواقع في في الظروف الراهنه وبعد
القرار
1701 وبعد انخراط بالواقع حزب الله في
تاييد هذا القرار المعروف تحت رقم
1701 بانه ليس هناك بالواقع من مصلحه
لبنانيه
ل السماح
باي انزلاق
غير يعني غير مخطط له نحو اي نوع من
الاشتباك لانه هذا بالنتيجه سيضر في
المصلحه الاستراتيجيه اللبنانيه وفي مصالح
لبنان الحيويه الاسرائيليين يدركون هذا
ولكن يبدو بانهم لديهم خشيه من التمرين
الذي جرى في يوم الارض سواء في الجولان او
في جنوب لبنان عندما زحفت
مظاهرات شعبيه واسعه باتجاه هذه الحدود
وحاولت ان تختار الشريط الفاصل ما بين ال
الان موضوع اختراق حائط هو اصعب بكثير من
اختراق شريط او زع شريط لذلك هو من نوع
التحوت للمستقبل شكرا جزيلا لك العميد
المتقاعد نزار عبد القادر الخبير في
الشؤون العسكريه وشكرا للكاتب الصحفي من
الناصره انطوان شلحت بهذا مشاهدينا الكرام
نكون قد وصلنا الى نهايه هذه الحلقه من
برنامج ما وراء الخبر دمتم في رعايه الله
والى
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
اللقاء
ان